é tããão pessoal de quem falar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um eu deixar só
muito obrigado você puxa fieira preparo
como está o amigo 5 mas na altura o pneu
estava em casa e como já não grava muito
tempo com nossos amigos o que nós que
sorrindo então hoje é o como estar um
cachorro lá né imaginem só a reação do
sul que contenham vírus clubes homem
olha aí sim isto muito malvado então
esse é o pedido que só espero que vocês
gostem já sabem vamos tentar bater o
recorde likes mas disputamos um vídeo
que mostre uma coisa muito importante
ser importantíssimo a companhia não só a
decorrer uma proteção para os top 100
djs do mundo e os novos media e portugal
precisam entrar nessa lista é uma coisa
muito importante mesmo vamos faltar em
um link de inscrição basta clicar em a
primeira coisa que vocês vão ter que
fazer é colocar o nosso país que neste
caso vai ser portugal e brasil pessoal
fãs do brasil vocês têm que ficar também
conta como fez é esse que é só fazer um
login no facebook é muito simples vai
aparecer um tempo continuar é só clicar
em seguida é só clicar na caixinha e
continuar esta situação precisa de dados
simples portanto é só vocês colocarem os
nomeou suleiman a nossa cidade o vosso
país ea ansiedade esquerda clique na
primeira segunda gatinha e continuar
aqui sim é um passo importantíssimo
preciso que vocês votem neste 5 de junho
o 1º de julho vai ser o que vos fala se
um grande amigo que é bom portanto é
muito importante que vocês votem mesmo
porque se eu tiver muitos votos nós
vamos fazer uma paródia e juntos então
esperem primeiro é a primeira vez que
uma com kevo é segundo gol dá entre
sério tom e 11 em quarto e diego miranda
e em quinto careto é só seguir essa
ordem de votação e clicar em continuar
enfrentando a gente que concluiu a
votação pessoal tive um princípio a
nossa tela e manda pra mim pro meu
instagram roupa da fama e levo estar
todos os setores onde vocês marcaram e
concluíram a votação ok eu voltar a
tempo e ainda vou fazer a prova de
qualquer butantan é muito importante que
vocês votem meu pessoal sério muito
ansioso fazer uma música muito louca e
agora você já sabe fazer pessoal paulo
em um vídeo faça uma votação e vamos lá
ao como assustar um cachorro um país
pronto para fazer o vídeo jockey
pronto sabe que faz sentido
para quem não sabe a sua opinião que o
chamado suzuki e gás e moído e tem seis
meses porque já conheço o uso que a
última vez que vocês ouviram foi neste
livro paraná e esse é um cão me olha que
bach e os eua terão de cinto papel e
como vocês podem ver o tio muito em
apenas dois meses é um tempo muito maior
o preço ursinho meu amor está muito
lindo e eu tenho tentado fazer alguns
vídeos curtos o que mais eu tenho alguma
vergonha da câmera então eu não tenho
esforçado muito do que gravar mas agora
estou bem calminho por isso eu vou
aproveitar para gravar com meus senhores
e o que o que falar coxim
eu não quero saber é porque se calhar é
um carro diz que só não falo nem narchi
pois claro tive muita sorte em ter o meu
amigo jean luc e agora só passeando ao
que realmente interessa neste vídeo nós
vamos reajustar look com o fato lobo eo
novo ainda não treinadas o quê porque
depois pode acontecer e pode não se
ajustar mas eu vou tentar fazer um e não
se preocupe pessoal vai ser um susto bem
leve não se preocupe o que tava isso que
aflige eu como muito brinca muito com o
dono voltou a tentar que empregaram
justin bieber como é que você acha que
eu não fazia isso vou dar muito errado
muito certo eu posso estar pode ser
muito engraçado ou então simplesmente o
poder com um lluku neste caso comigo e
pode ter uma geração se perguntarem onde
até gosto do mundo está olhando pra cima
eu não faço ideia mas vamos estar aqui e
vamos ver o que acontece na moda que
tenta obter um novo eu vou chamar o
daniel vai assistir vai ser o dante é
tentar ajustar o zouk é porque eu tenho
que sair com o uso que não tenha reação
que eu espera porque o uso que já
conheceu passa 99% tempo comigo então eu
posso reconhecer o porto física pode
conhecer o meu cheiro eu posso dizer que
o cabelo estiver fora eu sabe que sou eu
então se for mandante eu acho que vai
dar muito mais efeito e como o que
consegue ver com o estoril perdeu e vai
achar que aquilo é mesmo uma coisa
estranha
coisa vinda de fora um novo vindo de
fora de casa também vou chamar o dante
bola entra em uma missão que tinha
israel nem venham é uma branca pediu
calma pra cá opinião não é tão branco
azuki o zouk cuidadoso e eu só me checar
e com eles mesmo assim que funciona a
casa vai ter que o choroso tava então e
porque precisa nem por que tu vai ser só
de quem você quer o morro
o normal assim o mal vai dizer feliz não
e/ou o que acha que vai acontecer
eu acho que ele vai estar aqui me são
histórias do que tu vais querer se lobo
e vai estar fora de casa meu deus ea ele
mesmo e colocar as garras só usar tanto
a mais que o dobro como os gatos
eu acho que eu baixar mesmo que um ser
estranho meu deus
assim da avenida sua bonita e já ir se
acha inclusive que vai estar ou não
rafael tenta enganar como um bicho tão
bola fazer o cadastro no site da casa de
banho e fingir que se com o batom contra
a porta eu só comento e também o que é
que vocês acham desse globo do flamengo
muito embora eu tenho que estar
obrigatoriamente estar assim
não me imagino eu vi uma só nave andar
assim mas já sabe que uma pessoa sobre
uma coisa nada assim eu vou estar com
medo antes nenhum lobo anda anda pra
trás não há lobos que desde o aluguer
dos homens lobisomem meses mas por ser
um lobisomem construir um mundo pode
andar com lucas no contrário
isto assim o que acredito é hora de deus
é um canal foi muito fraca para fazer
como um louco não escuta não fazem isso
mas aqui uma coisa importante não é que
o cheiro eu acho que o assunto chegue ou
conhece portanto basta ter o usuário vai
ficar confuso porque vai ser um charme
mas não vai não vai ver a mim não mas
eles mas eles conhecem pelo cheiro
entanto basta ter um certo momento
tenhamos outra roupa eu vou esquecer
nunca usei mais de mim mas que elas só
pagarão para para indigitar o pessoal
fala que vai ser o pano ó eu não sei se
já tem alguma história ou assim mas
quando alguém toca a campainha uso que
fica fiquei muito tempo com meus
contatos para camping e fica ao pé da
porta é o levaram mesmo o que eu nunca
sabe quem é que está a tocar e quem
baixar a casa e normalmente é o pessoal
aqui da casa claro então quando eu vir
um lobo e nós vamos ver a reação dele
então vou deixar a câmara agravará o dem
vai lá por fora a tocar a campainha a
outra coisa nós temos outro cão aqui em
casa que é um ex quiosque do shopping
para então mesmo com o uso que não se
assuste pode ser que aí o que que é sic
também sustentam vamos ver a reação de 2
15 horas
que só terei tenta despistá lo não é
ninguém ninguém nos pressionados o que
tá tudo menos pessoas estão vendo que eu
queria assustar o zouk vanjoki que fez
esta queda
por isso em tudo e tem aquele que também
é linda linda
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
[Música]
todo meu bumbum rua rosa não correu nada
sobre o show eu só comentei o que vocês
acharam acham que funcionou assim que o
que restou ó são os segmentos do que
isso foi uma brincadeira evoluem com 51
que acha que acionou o alarme pouco ela
estava muito cartaz bem
o banco é obrigado a dar um bom oe
[Música]
ela não quer saber eu não quis dizer
nada só se vocês quiserem que eu gravar
um vídeo era banho azul que porque está
muito calor ele fora eu acho que eu
preciso de um banho de gelo é que estou
massa rússia então sofre muito com o
calor mas aqui em casa em pequim no mês
qualquer forma eu acho que era muito
louco fazer uma pontinha de gelo praia
então comecei o que vocês acham eu acho
que ele merece muito esse número disse
ele
vamos aproximar um resultado justo
tudo isto não tem medo de nada
[Música]